[Music]
good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight just about a decade ago
gender dysphoria was a fairly short
entry in abnormal psychology textbooks
it was a condition
so obscure that most people had never
heard of it that's changed
if you've got children in school you
know how common that disorder has become
in some places a third of girls in a
given class identify as a gender other
than the one in their birth certificates
most of them probably don't mean it five
years now they'll have moved on they're
going through what we used to call a
phase
but for an increasingly large number of
children that phase will not end
therapists will steer those children to
doctors who will almost immediately give
them powerful sex hormones
drugs whose long-term effects we cannot
know
in some cases those kids will then be
referred to surgeons who will mutilate
or remove their sex organs
permanently that is happening across the
country tonight
we rarely talk about the details of any
of it it's all good we're told
it's part of a vital long overdue
process of personal liberation and if
you stand in the way or ask too many
questions you are evil
okay but before we accept that version
of the story it is fair to ask
what are the details of the process
exactly and what are the consequences of
it
this weekend to its great credit the
news shows 60 minutes
asked those questions in a surprisingly
unflinching way
anchor leslie stahl interviewed patients
who had suffered from gender dysphoria
and asked them a simple question what
happened next
here's a woman called grace lyndinsky
smith explaining what she went through
after she went to her doctor
to treat her disorder watch she didn't
go really go into what my
gender dysphoria might have been
stemming from we only did a few sessions
they asked me so why do you want to go
on testosterone and i said
well being a woman just isn't working
for me anymore and they said
okay so that was that you got your
prescription for testosterone
yep being a woman just isn't working for
me
anymore okay here's some life altering
drugs that's
all it took and then it kept going
within just four months grace lindinsky
smith was in the operating room
having a double mastectomy
just four months after she started
testosterone
she says she was approved for a
mastectomy what's called
top surgery that she told us was
traumatic
i started to have a really disturbing
sense that like a part of my body
was missing almost a ghost limb feeling
about being like there's something that
should be there and the feeling really
surprised me but it was
really hard to deny and so she
detransitioned
by going off testosterone and then
went back to the clinic and she says
complain to the doctor that the process
didn't follow the w path guidelines i
can't believe that i
transition and detransitioned including
hormones and surgery in the course of
like less than one year it's completely
crazy
it's completely crazy yes it is it is
completely crazy it's also reckless
and cruel and totally unethical and yet
in the newly politicized atmosphere of
american medicine it is routine
another person who spoke to 60 minutes a
man identified as garrett
told leslie stahl that doctors rushed
him into a sex change operation
after just three months of taking female
hormones they castrated him
garrett from baton rouge louisiana went
from taking hormones
to getting his testicles removed he says
in just
three months whereas the current
guidelines call for continuous use for
a year i had never really been suicidal
before
until i had my breast augmentation and
about a week afterwards i wanted to like
actually kill myself like i had a plan
and i was gonna do it but
i just kept thinking about like my
family
to stop myself it kind of felt like
how am i ever gonna feel normal again
like other guys
now three months to castration
and then a week after the surgery he
wanted to kill himself
now that makes sense and yet it is the
precise
opposite of what activists claim the
opposite of the justification for these
procedures in the first place
if you ask questions about the wisdom of
gender reassignment surgery you will be
accused
immediately of pushing the vulnerable
towards self-harm
but in fact there's quite a bit of
evidence of the opposite gender
reassignment surgery and chemical
castration
cause depression and exacerbate mental
illness this is known
just five years ago a study by the obama
administration found no positive health
benefits from this so-called treatment
in a 2016 document called the proposed
decision memo for gender dysphoria and
gender reassignment surgery
obama officials concluded that quote
based on a thorough review of the
clinical evidence available at this time
there is not enough evidence to
determine whether gender reassignment
surgeries
improve health outcomes for medicare
beneficiaries with gender dysphoria
end quote so why wasn't there enough
evidence well the obama administration
found that many sex change patients were
quote lost to follow-up
why is that many of those patients
apparently had killed themselves
researchers in sweden found the same
thing after 10 years of study the swedes
concluded that people who underwent sex
reassignment surgery
were 19 more likely to commit suicide
the risk of psychiatric hospitalization
was nearly three times greater in other
words
it was an utter disaster yet strikingly
most americans are not aware of these
numbers they've never seen this research
they're not allowed to see it instead
they see a daily barrage of propaganda
most of it online made possible
by google and facebook that propaganda
has a very specific
effect as intended watch
how many of you feel that you were
blindly affirmed
i didn't get enough pushback on
transitioning
i went for two appointments and after
the second one i had like
my letter to go get on cross-sex
hormones
two visits that's it all four
tell us they learned about transitioning
on the internet
where there are transformation videos on
youtube
trans influencers and forums
we haven't said an awful lot of
complimentary things about leslie stahl
on this show but sunday night's piece
was a remarkably brave piece of
journalism leslie stahl
certainly didn't need to do that piece
she did it anyway
good for her and she's being punished
for it now within
minutes of that broadcast the usual
liars were accusing leslie stahl
and the people she interviewed of
committing an act of violence their
crime telling the truth
now those kinds of effect of attacks
have a chilling effect
on the rest of the population and that's
of course the point of making them
watch this psychologist describe how
many in medicine are simply too afraid
to care for their patients
do you have conversations with your
colleagues about this whole
area of accepting what young people are
saying too readily
yes everyone is very scared to speak up
because
we're afraid of not being seen as being
affirming or being supportive of these
young people or doing something to hurt
the trans community
but even some of the providers are trans
themselves and
share these concerns we're afraid to
speak up
because we don't want to be seen as not
affirming young people
in their decision to have these
surgeries and to take these
life-altering drugs
these young people how young are we
talking about at what age do we have to
respect
their personal decision to say undergo
chemical castration
well last year joe biden answered that
question he suggested that children as
young as
eight can change their sex
the idea that an eight-year-old child or
a ten-year-old child decides
you know i decided i want to be
transgender that's what i think i'd like
to be
make my life a lot easier there should
be zero discrimination
so as we said at the outset things are
moving awfully fast and most people have
no idea
what the details are so it seems worth
spending some time as 60 minutes did
over the weekend
talking to people who've actually been
through this process